and lastly
what should audiences take away from the
film after
your role of nora valentino and the
story i know we don't want to give away
the ending but in terms of a message
what would that message be
wow that's a good question uh
what should the audience take away from
after
well of course whatever however it
speaks to them
that's what would be important to me
i would hope that it moves them in some
way i would hope that
because it's a story about actual people
that
they might be able to be a bit of a
voyeur and and peek in on something they
might feel or see
and from the family all these fac i hope
they take away they enjoy seeing stories
about people
because that's what i thought we used to
go to the movies for to see stories
about
ourselves or or
people we love and
and that everybody's doing the best they
can that's all we can do
but sometimes we see a role uh someone
and we it's something in ourselves has
sparked them by seeing that portrayal
something like that right yeah yeah i
hope that
i hope that they're moved in some way
that they
can
understand someone's human frailty and
fragility the fragility of life
and that we all must face and
that we can get through it
you